[Música]
la región de puno en Perú sigue sacudida
por las protestas antigubernamentales el
gobierno condenó el incendio a una
comisaría del distrito de Juli por parte
de manifestantes los disturbios dejan
más de 20 personas heridas
el estado mexicano de Guerrero el
ejército lucha contra la producción de
cocaína que ha ido en aumento tras la
baja demanda de marihuana y heroína esta
droga sigue siendo una de las más
rentables del mundo
Venezuela rindió homenaje al
expresidente Hugo Chávez cuando se
cumplieron diez años del anuncio de su
muerte Seguidores del fallecido líder
así como políticos del oficialismo y
líderes internacionales se reunieron en
Caracas para una serie de actos
conmemorativos
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú al menos 27 personas resultaron
heridas en la región sureña de puno
después de que la policía disparara
armas de fuego para dispersar una marcha
tras esto los manifestantes quemaron una
comisaría el martes se cumplen tres
meses del inicio de las protestas día en
que la presidenta Dina boluarte acudirá
a la fiscalía para declarar sobre su
presunta responsabilidad Judith Muñoz
tiene más detalles
Julia mamani resultó herida iba a pagar
los servicios y se encontró una protesta
fue golpeada y disparada
su hija Marta mamaniz muestra los vídeos
en su teléfono las mujeres aymaras
esperan organizarse para ir a Lima
nosotros
este gobierno Usurpadora puede tratar de
esa manera a nuestros compatriotas
Así quedó la comisaría de policía de
Juli en la región sureña de puno el
incendio fue la respuesta de los
manifestantes al uso de armas de fuego
de la policía para dispersar la marcha
violencia en las protestas con especial
dureza en el sur del país pero también
en Lima la capital donde manifestantes
salieron el sábado a las calles
no nos vamos a cansar los peruanos
tenemos sangre inca y vamos a seguir
luchando somos chancas y no nos vamos a
chupar ante ella y ante nadie vamos a
seguir para morir moriremos luchando
nuestra patria el martes se cumplen tres
meses desde que Dina boluarte fuese
proclamada presidenta ese mismo día
tendrá que declarar ante la fiscalía que
busca determinar su responsabilidad en
las 60 muertes ocurridas durante las
protestas esto por la destitución y
posterior detención de Pedro Castillo
quien había tratado de disolver El
Congreso Un gobierno de emergencia
excepcional en el estado mexicano de
Guerrero los narcotraficantes
diversifican la producción de drogas con
la baja demanda de marihuana y heroína
han comenzado a sembrar coca planta que
al procesarla se convierte en cocaína y
que todavía sigue siendo una de las
drogas más rentables del mundo su
producción Aún es incipiente y el
ejército mexicano intenta destruir los
cultivos Andrés granadillo tiene los
detalles
un sobrevuelo por las montañas mexicanas
de Guerrero en busca de cultivos de Coca
los carteles mexicanos ahora la siembran
para adaptarse al millonario negocio del
tráfico de drogas es una actividad que
no había sido detectada anteriormente Y
bueno ya este como les mencioné en un
mes y medio llevamos de este durante el
2023 llevamos 27 plantillas localizados
durante años Los Campesinos de este
estado sembraron marihuana y Amapola
materia prima de la heroína pero cambió
el consumo en Estados Unidos hacia el
fentanilo estas drogas sintéticas 50
veces más poderosa que la heroína es
mucho más Adictiva y potencialmente
mortal ahora los cultivadores y los
narcotraficantes se decantan por la hoja
de coca con la que se produce cocaína
los grupos de la delincuencia organizada
tratan de obtener diversificar sus
actividades y Bueno yo creo que es una
experimentación de
del planteo de Coca la producción de
esta droga se Bolivia Perú y Colombia en
este último país se producen dos tercios
de la cocaína del mundo fueron unas 2000
toneladas en 2021 los carteles mexicanos
controlan casi toda la distribución de
este estupefaciente que proviene de
Colombia según inside Prime aunque han
extendido su producción a Honduras y
Guatemala países que hasta hace poco
eran utilizados solo para el tránsito de
las drogas frente a estos nuevos
cultivos en México se han erradicado
unos 360.000 metros cuadrados en los
últimos cuatro años la cocaína Aún es de
las drogas más rentables del mundo el
precio del kilo puede ser de más de mil
dólares en el país de origen mientras en
Europa puede costar 38 mil dólares
un nuevo caso de desaparición en el
marco del conflicto armado en Colombia
fue resuelto este domingo se trata del
líder social Isaac tuber que asesinado
en 1997 el hallazgo de los restos de
Isaac hace parte del plan Regional de
búsqueda de las autoridades colombianas
con el que pretenden esclarecer uno de
los grandes flagelos del conflicto de
ese país la desaparición el informe es
de Samuel Salgado
26 años de búsqueda que concluyeron con
las exequias de líder social Isaac
tuberquia nuestro destino no
familiares y amigos de Isaac finalmente
pudieron honrar su memoria no es olvidar
lo que era mi papá
al inclusive esto es como para que la
memoria de todo lo que notamos Uribe y
todo esto ahora sirva para aparecer para
hacer algo más Isaac tuberquía fue
asesinado el 24 de agosto de 1997 en el
marco del conflicto armado de Colombia
las autoridades presumen que su cuerpo
fue inhumado para no dejar rastro del
Crimen Sin embargo la unidad de
investigación de la jurisdicción
especial para la paz encontró los restos
óseos del líder social este organismo de
Justicia transicional ha sido creado
gracias al proceso de paz entre el
estado colombiano y la extinta guerrilla
de las FARC el trabajo fue coordinado
con la unidad de búsqueda de personas
desaparecidas aportamos en la
reconstrucción
strucción en la construcción de paz
respondiendo a las familias a la
comunidad el derecho de saber qué
ocurrió con su ser querido desaparecido
y aportamos en la reconstrucción del
tejido social de la comunidad de
urbarador la desaparición de tuberquía
en el departamento colombiano del chocó
es una de las 855 historias de personas
dadas por desaparecidas en la zona del
bajo atrato entre 1982 y 2016 que hacen
parte del plan Regional de búsqueda en
Colombia hay entre 80.000 y 100.000
desaparecidos por el conflicto armado
según la unidad de búsqueda un conflicto
cuya terminación es una de las
principales propuestas del actual
gobierno nacional con el proyecto de paz
total este domingo se conmemoraron en
Venezuela los 10 años desde que se
anunció la muerte del expresidente Hugo
Chávez el líder socialista sigue siendo
el político venezolano mejor valorado 23
años después de la Revolución
bolivariana el país está sumido en una
larga crisis económica
Carlos castañas es uno de los tantos
chavistas que hoy se siente decepcionado
el gobierno revolucionario al que tanto
apoyó lo desalojó de la propiedad que
cuidaba desde hace 25 años tras el
fallecimiento de sus dueños ahora vive
en una habitación en precarias
condiciones
me sacaron de ahí engañado diciéndome
que me iba a que me iba a dar una casita
que me iban a dar aunque sea un
kiosquito y no me lo dieron además de
estar sin una vivienda digna Carlos
tampoco cuenta con recursos para
adquirirlas esta básica como el 81% de
la población su pensión apenas alcanza
los 7 dólares
hago una sola comidita en el oeste de
Caracas Gregorio Velázquez Vocero del
Consejo comunal de la parroquia de Santa
Rosalía se encarga de organizar a los
habitantes del barrio para resolver sus
necesidades hoy también está a cargo de
promover la movilización para homenajear
Hugo Chávez para conmemorar la fecha que
se fue nuestro comandante aunque aún es
un cha orgulloso está consciente de que
el país a través de una crisis económica
que afecta a todos por igual sabe que ha
habido fallas pero aún así no culpa al
gobierno ni a la revolución bolivariana
los problemas económicos en Venezuela
son responsabilidad de el Imperio del
modelo capitalista a diez años el
fallecimiento de Hugo Chávez su proyecto
socialista no logró erigirse como fue
concebido para este analista político
Nicolás Maduro está creando un nuevo
modelo donde se contempla los valores
del capitalismo para conectar con otros
sectores de la sociedad ya se habla de
dólar claramente ya no se habla tanto
del Bolívar soberano como tal la moneda
nacional ahora se habla incluso de este
banca digital o criptomonedas eso era
impensable en la época de Chávez cada
cinco de marzo se le rinde homenaje al
fallecido presidente y algunos de sus
más cercanos aliados ya no conmemoran
con el gobierno porque no forman parte
del círculo de poder para la victoria
siempre hermano
en seremos seguidores como Gregorio
intentan mantener su legado vivo pero la
corrupción y las promesas incumplidas
han llevado a la decepción a muchos como
Carlos que esperaban más del proyecto
socialista hasta aquí es informativo
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]